j'enlève merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer quel sont les probables
irrégularités derrière l'attribution de
ce marché à une entreprise
luxembourgeoise
on se marche est une est extrêmement
longue saga qui a agité la belgique
pendant un petit temps disons la
première nommée dit que nous avions
constaté c'était la température de
lavage de ces masques donc du coup en
tissu température qui n'était pas
conforme à ce que les scientifiques
voulaient c'est à dire 60 degrés donc
lavage à l'eau avec un détergent à 60
degrés et quand on l'a reçu ces masques
on s'est rendu compte qu'il était
lavables qu'à 30 degrés pour 2 - rendre
possible 30 utilisation donc le cahier
des charges n'a pas été respecté c'est
bien cela écoutez là il ya disons un
trouble qui a été entretenu parce que
bon là vous connaissez la belgique est
un pays un petit peu surréaliste et et
donc la france le ministre de la santé
qui n'en sort plus a demandé aux
ministres de la défense de s'occuper des
masques
là ils ont tenté de gérer avec la
défense et il ya un cahier des charges
qui est établie mais apparemment en ne
respectant pas les nombres de
scientifiques au départ et donc on ne
connaît pas encore qui est le véritable
responsable de ce passage de nombre de
60 à 30 degrés là il ya une enquête en
cours on aimerait bien connaître la
vérité mais tout le monde dégage
responsabilités vous savez c'est un
petit peu la fuite quand il ya des
problèmes la défense ni c'est pas moi le
ministre de la santé dit c'est pas moins
enfin bon donc on est en train d'essayer
de voir pourquoi cette norme a changé
mais il est un fait que cette norme
au départ une obligation serait devenue
une recommandation de là à en tirer que
60 degrés peuvent être remplacés par 30
degrés c'est aller un petit peu vite
avec les rigueur scientifique
alors on va revenir sur les conséquences
éventuelles au niveau politique mais par
ailleurs est ce qu'il y avait des yeux
dit qu'ils étaient capables de fabriquer
ces masques en belgique et finalement
comment est ce que vous comprenez que ce
soit une société luxembourgeoise qui a
remporté le marché
bon il ya évidemment eu selon les
réglementations en vigueur des appels
d'offres et donc toutes les firmes que
ce soit belge ou étrangères ont pu
postuler
et c'est apparemment d'aucune firme
luxembourgeoise qui dit moins un siège
au luxembourg qui emportait une grosse
part du marché parce que indubitablement
les conditions offertes pécuniaire faire
téter les plus intéressantes on s'est
rendu compte en cours de route que
malheureusement cette société
luxembourgeoise c'est en fait une boîte
aux lettres au luxembourg on connaît
tous des avantages fiscaux du luxembourg
et que finalement ces masques ont été
fabriqués sous la responsabilité des
sociétés boîtes aux lettres ont été
fabriquées dans d'autres pays on parle
du vietnam et de la tunisie
éventuellement donc là déjà d'emblée on
avait dix ans s'était inquiétée d'un
petit peu savoir où aller tous ces
masques bon ils ont été livrés et c'est
là que les anomalies ont débuté avec ce
problème température tout d'abord et
puis un la position d'un label de
conformité qui malheureusement était une
usurpation d'un label anciens donc il ya
eu si vous les deux affaires troubles
dans cette histoire bon c'est assez
affolant pour la population parce que là
c'est la première fois que vous recevez
gratuitement des masques de notre de
notre état belge et ses masques ne donne
pas entière satisfaction et c'est assez
problématique effectivement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous parlez d'un scandale
sanitaire nationale écoutez c'est un
c'est un grand mot je crois que si on
connaît un petit peu la belgique on sait
que pour parler de scandale il faut il
faut beaucoup mais personnellement je
trouve que l'eee ou des erreurs commises
à certains moments le responsable n'est
pas encore connue je regrette que notre
ministre de la justice n'ait pas
endosser sa part de responsabilité il
parle un petit peu avec légèreté si vous
voulez alors que le
les scientifiques que je représente
puisque je suis président du conseil
super de la santé je représente toute
une série de scientifiques qui ont donné
des avis très précis qui malheureusement
n'ont pas été appliquée je trouve qu'il
a un problème là de responsabilité mais
donc en fait nous sommes en belgique je
sais qu'en france la la commission
denquête a déjà commencé mais nous
sommes en belgique en train d'essayer de
comprendre et on est parti dans l'est
entre guillemets règlement de comptes
merci beaucoup j'en mets d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes le président du conseil supérieur
de la santé en belgique